[Musique]
la vice présidente du département en
charge de l'éducation
marie-lise soubadou accompagné de
conseillers départementaux du secteur
c'est randy d'une part au collège
terrain fleury pour se rendre compte de
visu des moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour
améliorer les conditions de travail et
de vie des enfants est actuellement mais
on y est on est un petit peu en stand by
parce que le professeur de sur le champ
et j'avais l'aimantation un service ne
peut pas mettre en oeuvre toutes les
compétences attendues pour nous donc on
a des élèves et becky essentiellement
sur ce champ là découvrent les métiers
du présentiel
la directrice était la visite du collège
et dans un cours pratique suivie par une
classe de segpa ont tous un peu au
matériel et aux matériaux vois tu piges
pas faire plus tard dans les voiles
puis dans un cours de couture à elle
travaille beaucoup sur la découverte des
métiers
assis autour d'une table avec le tableau
mais au niveau de la manipulation et au
niveau de la découverte et tout ce qu'on
attend des gestes techniques de nos
élèves ça reste limitée et l'autre par
au collège trois mares pour assurer la
communauté éducative de l'entière
soutien de la collectivité aux chefs
d'établissement de ne pas s'inquiéter
nous sommes à leurs côtés nous
veillerons à ce que nous les humains
parce que nous sommes à 4 aujourd'hui et
moi-même près 10 présidente du
d'éducation nous veillerons à ce que les
travaux tout ce qui a été endommagé
puisse être réparé et que les élèves
bien évidemment ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'intérêt premier de tout un chacun dans
les collèges c'est l'intérêt de l'élève
qui prime
donc nous veillerons à ce que les
et un confort et puissent travailler
dans de très bonnes conditions dans les
collèges le département est à la charge
de 60 17 collèges publics du lille et le
29 janvier dernier
soixante mille collégiens repris les
cours dans ces établissements
je reviendrai d'accord il faisait part
de toutes vos données ans et dans la
mesure du possible si on est venu aussi
nombreux c'est parce qu'on veut
travailler avec vous construire avec
vous
donc c'est faites nous confiance va
essayer en tout les cas de faire de
notre mieux pour que les choses avancent
et pour nos élèves parce que c'est
l'intérêt de nos enfants et pour
l'équipe aussi qu'il travaille tout
[Musique]